joining us now sir canoes Sarah Carter
from the hill John Solomon attorney
Victoria ton C she's representing that
FBI informant at the center of this
latest Clinton Foundation scandal I'll
start with you Victoria this is your
client he wanted to tell Congress about
all the bribery all the scheming all of
the kickbacks all the corruption he had
the information he wanted to tell a
story what happened
well when he started working for the FBI
in 2009 they had him sign what's called
an NDA a nondisclosure agreement they
never gave him a copy of it and when he
went public in 2016 way after all this
case stuff was done the Justice
Department under Loretta Lynch called
him and threatened him with his freedom
if he violated the NDA now I've never
heard of an NDA
that had a criminal penalty for
violation but they won't show him a copy
of it so we decided to go to the members
of Congress in the Senate and I have
breaking news for you Sean while I was
in makeup I got a letter from chairman
Grassley asking my client to give them
information now what this does is set up
a constitutional issue because the
executive branch cannot say to someone
don't you give information to the
legislature so it will be a very
interesting thing to see how the Justice
Department so they have the power to
lift that NDA
that would be amazing so we've got Sarah
bribery kickbacks extortion money
laundering and Vladimir Putin gets 20%
of our uranium all those money gets
kicked back I'm always a big believer
follow the money
Vladimir Putin was up to his eyeballs
infiltrating it is a real national
security issue getting our uranium it
was his goal it was a
counterintelligence investigation to
begin with that's what my sources are
saying now this started out as a
counterintelligence investigation and
what happened was you know the Russians
that the United States had known that
the Russians wanted to get by the
disarmament process they wanted to
penetrate
American markets so then they could have
Russian dependencies so people would be
dependent on Russia and that's what they
were doing all along and this is how
they did it they reached out to people
that they knew would help them move
legislation through move the process
through quickly and apparently they
found it especially here in the United
States and you know I we don't want to
jump the gun here we know this is
ongoing and the Senate is now
investigating this but there was a large
number of kickbacks and bribes and
schemes that we still haven't uncovered
yet John you broke this forward this is
important about the informant and if
Grassley is going to Senator Grassley's
going to allow this informant to talk in
the Justice Department who would have to
sign off specifically so Victoria's
being a great attorney and I've known
her for many years and I'd hire myself
in a second who would have to sign off
on this it would have to be the Justice
Department right it would be though the
FBI might have a say too because they
would be concerned about what
information methods and sources might be
divulged by him so I think it's gonna be
a two-tiered response be I first and the
Justice Department second where did the
money come from because you talked about
money laundering where did the money
that got into the Clinton Foundation
come from well we don't know that yet I
think we have to find that out we do
know that the money for the kickbacks
came from the form of the contract so
the Russian company would pay a contract
in the United States and the contractor
then would kick that money back to
enrich Vladimir Putin's buddies back in
Russia that is what's been established
in the court case where the money came
from for the Clinton Foundation we don't
know except what's in the public records
we know a bank interested in the deal
gave Bill Clinton five hundred thousand
dollars SpeedTree we know other people
interesting the deal donated millions of
dollars over the years is it possible
though this is a real Russia collusion
influence-peddling
bribery extortion kickbacks scam now now
the question is who needs to get on this
victoria last word well I think Bob
Miller needs to get off of it point I
can't imagine that he doesn't have a
conflict well good well very good point
all right any breaking news tomorrow
guys Sarah John
stay tuned I know what stay tuned means
in your world thank